the largest
single-family land landlord in the u.s
boosted rents by eight percent
nationwide in the second quarter as
company hike prices amid strong demand
for suburban
properties the company would show more
than 80 000 homes boost
rent by 5.8 percent on renewals
and 14 on leases signed by new tenants
whole
so if your rent is two grand a month is
20 to 80 now is what it is
according to a statement wednesday the
company also posted core condos
from operations of 37 cents per share
beating the average analyst expectation
of 35 cents
for the key metric barry well this is a
big story because
when you talk about the real estate
market right now it's easy for people to
bash housing bash the real estate market
because they're talking about
the most recent numbers is 16.6
appreciation on homes
unless i agree that's too hot you know
we'd love to see it come back down
but you also have to think about what's
the alternative is certainly not going
to want to pitch a tent so
if you're going to go rent your rent on
your transaction is going to have gone
up 14
as well so it's almost keeping pace but
the big difference is is that with a
purchase
if you get a fixed rate mortgage which
is the vast vast vast majority
maybe you see your taxes go up slightly
but that's a pretty small portion of
your overall payment if your taxes went
up two percent
that's a small portion in general
probably less than one percent of your
payment
but on rents they're going up almost six
percent a year and you get hit with that
every year
so over time the purchase definitely has
a lot of benefit to it
but people are really bashing the
housing market i understand that i mean
we were on last time we talked about a
lot of these things
look you have to be careful you have to
make your own decisions and different
markets are different
but in general if you go by the rules of
supply and demand
where's the new supply going to come
from to override the demand for housing
to cause prices to drop precipitously
like so many people are saying right i
mean
and where is the supply going to come
from well that's more houses or what
well here's the thing people say okay
well what if a lot of people
put their homes on the market and sell
them but
where are they going to live you know
they're probably they're going to keep
revenue neutral
and we we talked about this last time
but you've got a lot of influx of
first-time home buyers are going to come
in so
builders are going to put them up but
they just it's hard for them it's hard
to deliver because of chips with
appliances to get certificates of
occupancy
it's hard for builders because of land
and the costs that are involved
it's really tough to build a home for
less than 350 000
and that's really where the demand is
needed so it's it's
not an easy solution here but in the
midst of it
it seems like home prices are going to
be pretty decently supported
i don't see this big pressly and people
love to compare it to like the stock
market
the thing of it is for me is i could
sell a stock and be fined i don't have
to do anything
but if i sell my home there comes a
question is where am i going to live
replace it you know where where am i
going to stay now if it's an investment
property that's one thing but
sure the percentage of investors is not
like it was in 2007 2007-2008 we had you
know
one person buying several homes remember
the movie the big shorts
of course and a condo right so
um how's she doing by the way well you
know i don't know
i lived it there for two years it was
great that's great free rest so
brian's i'll see you there friday night
i got a vote real quick story about
o'brien sorry barry
real quick story so we're at o'brien's
over here in boca raton man
and then we'll get back to the housing
but we we're adam's buying out the whole
bar adam spent about a thousand dollars
on white cars
a thousand dollars on white i don't know
if i know i would i would
i would have taken it down you're a girl
you were drinking you got a drink that
night
dude we were celebrating karaoke so
there's this absolute
smoke show smoke show adam buys i don't
know a thousand dollars with the white
clothes finally gets to talking to her
and then goes comes over to me and i was
like bro did you get her number he goes
dude
i already had her number in my phone
completely forgot that he had this
girl's number
so yeah uh the biggest point of the
story is he found
his favorite bar of all time i love the
place anyway
let me let me go back to asking a
question here i mean i got a question
for you about this
thank you so random story so so the 14
so the 14
so they're raising rents on new tenants
14 existing 5.8
the numbers on inflation came out last
month was what five point four percent
and that's only a month of course it's
4.5 that's year over year
year over year yeah okay so four that's
on cpi pce
which the fed likes better but it's a
stupid measure so give me the number
which one is more of a number to look at
when it comes to cpi is more accurate
four point five percent looks like yeah
four and a half percent let's say four
and a half percent so if this is
5.8 percent on existing it's 14
on new is this
they have analysts analysts are not
going to give numbers like this for the
hell of it
are the analysts assuming that inflation
is going to go to percentages like 14 to
match it or are they just saying
nope there's a demand we can charge this
number they're going to pay for it
okay inflation probably comes down a
little bit but this is just because
there's just too much demand
it's it's you're talking about florida
or nationally we're talking nationally
these are national numbers but really if
you go to most parts of the country it's
a similar story
there's just too much damn demand and we
don't have enough supply on the market
let me let me ask you this because
because that this is something that in
jersey city and brooklyn where i came
from like i never understood and then it
was brooklyn like me
nice man what part bensonhurst nice man
what's second avenue p graves then
wait a minute did you go to ps177 no uh
no no no i went to the school right
there on daylily avenue p west first
i was on west 7th saint simon and jude
in new jersey okay i got you i remember
when we were chilling granada
where'd you go to high school again
glendale
1.8 gpa me too bro so the uh this is
what i don't understand
and it was explained to me as as reits
were the problem because there are
entire blocks
there are entire blocks that stay empty
for years and
the rents never come down so everybody
heard a year ago two years ago new
york's dead
go move to new york everybody's leaving
the rents have not gone down so they
they package these things and it they
are it's okay for them to lose money
because apparently this is apparently
the scam that they do there's like three
parts of the scam
all right or it's completely legal but
it's a scam the first thing that they do
you're you're only allowed a three
percent uh raise in
in rent year over year so what they'll
do is they'll make the rent 2500 but
give you three months free
so you're you're paying you know 1900
and then the rent goes up
after a year to you know 26. then
they they take the first two floors of
these luxury high-rises and they section
eight them
so people are are getting it on
government dime they're getting they're
spending eight hundred dollars for these
2500
apartments then it's pre-paid for by the
government apparently section 8.
and then the rest of it they packaged
together like bizuto and all these other
real estate firms
that run these they packaged it together
and then they sell it on the back end
as as a reit so and that read apparently
is x amount of units times x amount of
of average
rent per month whether they rent it or
not yeah but this is invitation homes
these are single family homes that
they own and that they're renting out
these are real numbers okay yeah this is
not a scam invitation homes
is the largest landlord in the united
states and these are all single-family
homes so they're very representative of
what's really going on in the world
if if so why why is rent staying
stagnant
it's not it's going up fourteen percent
yeah yeah that's what that's why there's
nobody buying homes people are buying
homes there's
there's a ton of people buying homes in
fact when you look at the numbers you
have to be careful like the mortgage
bankers association last week
they come out with this story they got
so many headlines and it said purchase
applications year over year are down 18
first of all 18 from a feverish pace
secondarily
what they don't do and this is why you
got to be careful with statistics and
you have to go deep
most people don't when you take a look
at the numbers
mortgage applications means you took out
a mortgage to buy a home
well what about people that paid cash a
year ago 16
of individuals paid cash the recent
numbers it's almost 24
so there is a drop but it's not 18 it's
9 but inventory is 20
less prices are 16 percent higher
there's less available so yes they're
going to be less transactions happening
but these are off of very very high
numbers you have to
differentiate real estate in two parts
one is real estate the driver of gdp
and how many transactions are generated
and then there's real estate if i buy a
home
will i make money on it or lose money on
it if i make money or lose money on it
right now
it's difficult to buy a home it's a
lousy time to buy a home
but if you do it the benefits are really
really great and then you have to think
about why
why is why is it why did you say it's
how easy to buy a home right now it's
awful to buy a home right now because
you have to likely bid over asking price
you have a very difficult time because
of lack of inventory
sellers are going to dictate terms and
often times but it's kind of like look
it also sucks to diet it also sucks to
work out sometimes right
but you do it because the benefits are
good and when you think about
this this is not about perfect it's
about choice where am i going to live am
i going to live in a home that i own or
am i going to live at home
what is the opposing argument to what
you just said so play the devil's
advocate play
argue your own argument and your own
world you're in your world how do you
argue what you just said
it's very difficult to argue against it
if you understand the numbers because
where am i what
if i believe that the house what is the
common argument
the argument is home prices are going to
drop because they went up okay
so so i'll stay safe renting
and this way i'll be in a position where
if home prices drop i benefited by that
right so
renting is it's not the same as on the
sidelines because you're still paying to
put a roof over your head whereas
that could be giving you some of that
towards principle and then the question
is appreciation right
so it's it's hard to argue against it
once you start to see what the facts are
if you believe there's a housing crash
in housing bubble
then you certainly shouldn't purchase a
home i don't believe that i think that
home prices
are going to be driven higher so you're
saying the fed is lying to us the fed is
lying to us and it's
it's uh it's very interesting because
the number that almost everybody throws
out there's how much is the fed buying
your mortgage-backed securities to keep
rates low and they say 40 billion
dollars a month that's
a month that's complete [ __ ] that's
someone like the government to lie to us
though are you sure
yeah i know right so um here's
the truth of it is they're buying more
than 100 billion dollars a month which
is an incredible number
now last year they said they were going
to buy starting march 40 billion dollars
in mortgage-backed securities
so if you take starting in march they'll
be 10 months right so that'd be 400
billion how much they bought
2 trillion they've what 50 of the
marketplace
now this year they say they're buying 40
billion that's all you see 40 billion 40
billion they change the language in the
fed statement very
likely to say oh at least but it's over
100 billion that they're buying this
year
for the first six months they bought 682
billion dollars
if it would have been the real if they
would have been telling us 40 billion
and done that that's only 240 billion
so the thing that they're not talking
about is the reinvestment in other words
they're holding
four trillion dollars of mortgage-backed
securities as somebody refinances or
sells their home
instead of taking that money in they're
taking the same money and buying back
and they're saying we're not going to
count that it's like this is not a
ridiculous argument
that's like saying don't count my food
consumption in gdp because i'm just
replacing it
if my phone breaks and i buy a new one
don't count that at gdp don't count that
as a sale because i'm just replacing it
that's a bs argument
they're buying an enorm they're buying
40 percent
of the mortgage market right now 40 of
the mortgage market so all this talk
about
tapering and is that going to destroy
housing if they taper it's not going to
be a reinvestment they're not going to
touch that
so if they if they say they're the new
purchases of 40
if they cut it to 30 or 25 that's tiny
it's very very small it's not going to
impact let me ask you break this down
this is like the macro economics of real
estate
and that's great how does this affect
the person that's maybe considering
buying a house the bottom line
considering renting the bottom line is
rates are going to fluctuate certainly
but they're not going to go way up there
in fact
i believe that rates will probably head
lower because the stimulus that we've
seen it wears off we know this factually
stimulus it gives you a big boost it
causes a little inflation it causes
economic activity
but then what's left behind is the debt
and that debt has to be serviced and
paid
and that slows down the economy we've
seen it everywhere in the world
everywhere through time
and when you see the debt way on the
economy it drives interest rates slower
i think that the time
we live in a world of perpetual stimulus
though man i mean that's the
well that's the thing there's already a
little bit of pushback on the additional
stimulus that's going out there but
you're right that's the other argument
is do we continue to see that stimulus
and does that eventually
are they considering another stimulus
because all i hear is oh yeah always
baby
they're they're blowing out another way
to take your money and put it in their
pocket but the big thing on the agenda
is the infrastructure bill right now i'm
not hearing a lot about it
what do you think that is what do you
think that is but when you look at it
it's not checks human infrastructure
when you look at when you look at the
infrastructure bill there's a lot of
aspects of it on the second phase that
they want to do
which are nests aren't necessarily up to
a separate structure
it is controlled the balance sheet for
the fed
is eight trillion dollars which is an
insane amount of money but the levels of
stimulus that we've seen are incredible
in 2020 had 2.8 trillion um in
in march and april and then you had
december was 900 billion and then
another 1.9 trillion of march is another
2.8 trillion
it's insane the amount of money what do
you do with the lenders man like
like i'm in the market right now and
they're they want no matter what
20 percent down and they i they're
they're telling me i don't want 20
percent i got a lot of
income and i'm like yeah i have a lapse
in income a lot of people
like everybody has a lot no by the way a
lot of people think that they want 20
down that's that that's a common thing
that people believe but it's not true
you can purchase a home with five
percent with three percent three and a
half percent down
there's plenty of programs available fha
loan fha will do that but also
just conventional loans you could deal
with three percent or five percent out
of what should gerard do
you should in my humble opinion gerard
you want to try and be careful on the
purchase i know it's not
easy but i would definitely purchase a
home you don't need 20 down
and i think that you'll do well with
that over time i really did depends look
if you're gonna be buying a home
and then selling it a year from now
that's very risky but if you're saying
like most people i'm going to buy this
home
i'm going to live there for eight or
nine years you'll probably do really
really well so residents
forget investing that's that's basically
no i wouldn't say
investing in really good investments
what do you mean so from what
if i can kind of uh distill what you're
saying is like okay if
you're looking for a residential
purchase now is it as good a time
as you'll get but if you're looking for
an investment purchase you should
probably kick the can
no i think that an investment purchase
is is also a good idea as well i mean
again you have to be careful about that
but
there's a very good probability that the
value over time
will continue to do pretty well now as a
realtor would you ever tell me there's a
bad time to buy a house
yeah no listen uh when when we were
inside the right question
okay so so you know you could pull up my
clips on cnbc i used to get hate mail
because i said to people do not buy home
in 2007 or don't
you know this is a risky time i didn't
like in fact i sold my company because i
did not believe
the market just didn't make sense but
that was a time where
we had demand was waning because 33
years before that
you had abortions were legalized less
first-time home buyers coming in and
builders in 2006 built more homes than
they ever built they built two million
homes
so it's the opposite of today you had
too much demand too much supply
rather not enough demand it was
troublesome plus
one person was buying more than one home
on average whereas today
the biggest thing you said on the last
time just everybody knows you're you
know barry
for some who don't know your three-time
zillow uh what what is what is uh
it's called the ball what is this not
the golden ball
that's a different that's a vegas that's
vivid this is different this is sell
real estate crystal balls
that's a wrong convention that's the
wrong convention buddy that's vegas
convention vivid that's golden ball this
is crystal ball
predicting what's going to happen to
real estate the ball but
one of the things he said last time the
difference between 0.708 and today is
inventory
we had 3.8 i think the number 7.7
million
with 116 million households that's
insane to think about versus today it's
only
what do we have right now more than a
million million 40 000.2 right now yeah
supply and demand that's a big supply
but hold on now you've got almost 130
million so you got you know
almost 14 million more households with
almost three million less homes
yeah so statistically it's different
data that says
if i'm a realtor and i'm in that
business that's the argument i'll be
telling every client i'm selling a house
to
so if you enjoy this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye